[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
depuis que le corona a commencé, netanyahu
essaie de
faire d'Israël une dictature complète, il
adopte tellement de
lois illégales que le shin parie que les
services secrets israéliens nous espionnent en
essayant de faire tomber la knesset, notre
parlement, donc nous sommes fondamentalement
ici à droite à gauche
des religieux laïcs de
nombreuses organisations et de nombreux groupes
disent simplement la même chose que nous ne voulons plus que
Netanyahu soit Premier ministre, il est
corrompu
et tout ce qu'il fait est pour son propre
gain
et contre les citoyens que
nous demandons au gouvernement de payer
compensation
pour la période pendant laquelle nous serons fermés
afin que nous puissions revenir et recommencer à travailler
nous sommes venus protester contre le
gouvernement israélien qui a fermé
toutes nos entreprises et j'ai dû licencier tous
mes travailleurs et nous ne recevons pas d'argent
des israéliens  gouvernement
[Musique]
[Musique] d'
accord
[Musique]
étranger
vous